[Musique]
oui je sais que vous l'attendez avec
impatience tous les lundis c'est la
chronique sport de michael et demi
d'euros bonsoir bonsoir greuil tous les
lundis donc vous revenez sur les
résultats sportifs du département est ce
qui s'est passé dans le week-end on
parlait football justement dans ce
reportage de vous michael il y avait du
football notamment
c'est ça avec ou à créer la surprise
l'équipe 2 de la commune qui joue en
noir s'est imposé sur la pelouse de
verneuil lors de la 19e journée de
deuxième division de district après
avoir mené 2 à 0 les visiteurs se sont
fait rejoindre à deux partout sur ce
penalty les adresses les hardricourt toi
je vais y arriver profiteront des
espaces en fin de match pour marquer
trois buts sur contre attaque score
final 5 à 2 on écoute les réactions
les gars ont respecté les consignes ce
n'était pas un match facile on
s'attendait on savait qu'on allait avoir
une opposition difficile face à verneuil
qui jouait le haut du tableau mais dans
l'ensemble on voit là les gars ont sorti
le match qu'il fallait quand il fallait
on a manqué un peu de réalisme après ils
ont su nous contrer ils ont été
efficaces
du coup mené 2-0 à la mi-temps donc
difficile mais voilà on a essayé de
pousser ça n'a pas marché
après ce match vernet pointe à la
troisième place du classement à deux
journées de la fin du championnat de son
côté arrêt court en difficulté depuis le
début de la saison respire l'équipe est
désormais 9e et s'éloigne de la zone de
relégation après moi juste comment on
appelle les habitants d'hardricourt en
quelques courtes wade est arrivé hier
direction maintenant les parquets de
basket alors le chesnay-versailles jouer
ce week-end les quarts de finale de
playoffs de prénationale et l'équipe est
toujours en course pour la montée en fin
de saison les yvelinois se sont imposés
chez le basket paris 14 sur le score de
73 à 52 et prennent une sérieuse option
avant de disputer le match retour samedi
prochain et les joueurs ne veulent pas
entendre parler de remontée dans les
coudes bombassei l'un des joueurs de
l'équipe de l'entente le chesnay
versailles après
le match est programmé ce samedi soir à
20 heures face au basket paris 14 au
gymnase mont boron
merci michael tous ces résultats et bien
d'autres choses encore dans votre
émission le 7-8 sport c'est après ce
journal